ah ben merde alors pour licenciement
c'était encore du cul vraiment l'esprit
mal placé
les relations sexuelles ont toujours été
des intéressés le seul avec qui j'aurais
pu coucher utile c'est vous je serai bon
jour je m'appelle lambert gt1 dépendance
sexuelle et il est abstinent depuis 10
mois 3 semaines et 2 jours
il est temps que tu reprennes contact en
douceur avec les femmes mais attention
rien pendant les premières semaines
c'est comme après un régime
je peux vous baisez va je peux vous
aider
j'ai rendez vous pour un travail si
j'arrive en boitant ça la fout mal non
mais pour le classement en fait en rien
cumulé beaucoup d'expérience si on
reçoit des couples c'est pour ça qu'on
travaille en duo que moi aussi j'ai
beaucoup travaillé en duo celle ci est
arrivé une fois qu'une seule fois
évidemment tu n'as que deux secrétaires
mais à part ça vous faites l'amour tous
les jours les semaines les mois
tous les ans je dit s'il veut graver
cette fille elle est dangereuse
votre bain est en train de virer
il n'a pas ressenti quelque chose il
revient la charge sans arrêt elle est
prête à tous ces mois avant en fille
ah parce que vous le cul ça vous plaît
pas non l'enjeu majeur c'est le temps de
la parole de les changes
je peux l'appeler une fois par des
changes physique
quand j'ai vu sur n'importe quoi sur
n'importe qui merci franchement écouter
un tournemain terrassement plusieurs
coups plusieurs soirs c'est mieux